et si nous sommes à blotzheim
donc c'est le deuxième héros que nous
vous posons dans le haut rhin donc après
rouffach qu'on a posé le 2 mars
donc c'est toujours un moment fort dans
le projet et nero c'est ce cas le plus
spectaculaire des gros engins une rue de
130 tonnes le noeud de raccordement de
blood ça il permettra de relier à la
fibre optique la quinzaine de communes
des environs
les trois premières sont buschwiller et
zinc et rosenau notre rôle sur le projet
a été toute la conception
administratives pour la définition des
besoins et des envies de la commune par
rapport à l'intégration du nro sur leur
banc communal donc une fois une fois la
réunion en mairie effectué nous déposer
un dossier
donc selon les cas ce dossier peut durer
deux mois en fonction s'il ya des
monuments historiques
tout absolument tout se fait en
concertation constante avec des
municipalités la société madère à
guebwiller nous a réalisé
tout ce qu'était infrastructures mur en
retz les plateformes de déchargement du
nro et ensuite nous avons la pause en
proprement dit du bâtiment du chêne-vert
qui vient en provenance de marseille qui
nous est fourni par la société cegelec
un poids de 30 tonnes à manier comme de
la dentelle est apposée au millimètre
près au terme de plusieurs heures
d'efforts pour la suite mes collègues
câblée l'ensemble du bâtiment
avec la fibre optique qui vont ramener
l'énergie également pour ensuite
déployer la fibre sur l'ensemble du
territoire de gloucester et nero qui
pourra regrouper entre quinze et vingt
mille prise et voilà à quoi ressemble un
noeud de raccordement optique les
infrastructures nécessaires au réseau
rosacée aux opérateurs télécoms seront
là avec climatisation et surveillance à
distance par la suite sur un petit
aménagement paysager qui sera qui sera
réalisé
mais en place de clôtures places de
stationnement les quarante sept noeuds
de raccordement optique que rosa sera
déployée sur le territoire alsacien ont
tous bénéficié d'une intégration
urbanistique et paysagère
c'est un projet très intéressant de par
sa diversité technique de mise en place
chaque nro a sa spécificité de pause ont
du coup c'est un projet mais avant tout
ce sont des hommes et pour moi ce qui me
plaît le plus là dedans c'est sur ces
aliments et c'est avec les hommes qui
ont construit les beaux ouvrages